we can only confirm that unfortunately  we have six deceased we have transported  now hundreds of people to various  hospitals Sam Phillips can give you more  details in that regard we also need to  get out information about how people can  contact or find out about any of the  individuals who were on the train and to  the extent that we have information  about them obviously they'll get that  information as well Sam Phillips is  going to come up and give you some of  that information then you'll hear from  NTSB their representative as well as  Amtrak will come back with any wrap-up  information open up the questions will  answer what we can answer everything  still at this point 12-plus hours into  this tragic event is still preliminary  information and subject to change